[Music]  this is a lined seahorse  a naturally poor swimmer the lined  seahorse is often found latched to  aquatic vegetation like seagrass or  sargassum  rather than hunt it camouflages itself  and waits for its prey to pass  its eyes can move independently of one  another allowing it to scan its  surroundings  its habitat is extensive it can be found  along the eastern coast of the americas  as north as nova scotia and as south as  uruguay they're quite small reaching  only up to six inches in length  because of coastal growth and pollution  the natural habitat of the lined  seahorse has been  diminishing this paired with its common  use in chinese medicine and the aquarium  trade has seen its numbers dwindling  since the late 1990s  this is the lined seahorse  [Music]  you